today i've been thinking a lot about
perfectionism
which is something that i've struggled
with myself quite a bit my entire life
and i certainly can't say that i
have entirely mastered
or even fully understood what's going on
within my own
perfectionism and those tendencies
i started thinking about it today in
part because i'm beginning another
semester with with students and i have
them do these these self-evaluations at
the beginning
where among
other things i have them i ask them
about their own
their own tendencies and what they think
might might
interfere with them doing well in my
classes and
there tend to be about four main things
semester after semester that i see
students bringing up you know and and
they're not all about perfectionism
although some of them have some
connections they
they talk about
time management skills
big big problem it was always a big
problem for me as well
writing abilities
they talk about procrastination which
which is connected with time management
but is somewhat a bit different
and then the i would say a good
third of my students
maybe even half of them depending on the
class bring up being perfectionists and
this sometimes ties together with
procrastination
and with with other other issues as well
so i i want to talk about this and i'm
shooting this video in part for my my
students
but i think that this is
useful to think about outside of just a
strictly academic context because
it's a perennial
problem that that comes up over and over
again in people's lives you know
academic lives personal lives uh
our political engagements um
many other things i mean it holds us
back in many ways from from things so i
want to talk about perfectionism uh in
general what does it mean to be a
perfectionist
um
well you know if we want to answer that
we should think about what does a
perfectionist look like and if you're a
perfectionist you can you know look in
the mirror but it's not quite so easy
because one of the things that you
notice
about this this tendency is it leads to
or it
both leads to and it comes out of a lack
of self-knowledge that comes
not from any sort of deficit
necessarily in the person but from
not paying attention to what's going on
because you're so focused on on other
things instead
it's sort of like doing sleight of hand
with yourself all the time and
fooling yourself where you're both the
magician
and the the audience and so you're taken
in by by a self-illusion
um
how can you identify a perfectionist
you know that that may be another way of
thinking about it
so you know what would you do in order
to
answer that question well you could look
at
what do perfectionists actually do
but
that's not that helpful because what a
perfectionist does is very much the same
as what other people are doing including
other high performing people
so it's not simply a question of what
one does it's more a question of how one
does it the mode in which one one does
things
um
how much they do it
so it's the way in which things are done
and it's the degree or the amount
that's different than just the the sheer
you know
facticity of something being done
those are external things that you can
look at having to do with actions
if you're looking at yourself you're
looking at other people
and you know we can't you know see
another person's soul in its entirety or
their mind or their personality as an
entire whole but you can't do that with
your own either but we we are we do have
some degree of access to each other's
psyches you know
that's what it means to have an
interpersonal
life with with other human beings to
have
what we call intersubjectivity in
phenomenology
fancy word for saying well we inhabit a
common world in which we can actually
peer into things to some
degree would we talk about in that case
we could say well how does a
perfectionist feel
what do what does that look like or what
what can you sense coming from them and
you know you can sense it
at least in myself not just through
self-reflection uh you know seeing how i
feel about things but i can tell
sometimes through
email interactions with a student that
they have these perfectionist tendencies
and which direction they're going you
can you can sense the
the anxiety or the
need for for things to be very very
clear and the path to be
charted out so that they can they can
plow ahead and get it all done
um
you can also ask about motives you know
with a perfectionist what is what is
their actual motive
and you can say
well you know to do something to the
highest degree to make it perfect to be
perfect in every way
but then you know we have to clarify
that and
and i think it's worth thinking about
what we mean by that
so another thing that we can look at
we've got these two dimensions of what
does a perfectionist do you know what's
their motive behavior
what is their affect or their motive
like you know their interior
disposition
what don't they do
that's another important question to ask
yourself what what separates a
perfectionist from a non-perfectionist
it's not just what they do
it's also what they don't do
and or what they don't have or what they
don't exhibit and and one of the things
that goes along with that i think is
again i'm drawing from my own experience
and the experience of many others that
i've interacted with a a kind of lack of
contentment
not necessarily an inability
but certainly a failure to appreciate
what it is that one has actually
attained you know you look at
perfectionists
and they often get quite a bit done but
they're not they're not
thrilled about what they they got done
and they tend to focus on
the
the lack or the
the small failures or
the um
the negativity of
of what they've gotten done rather than
on the positive achievement that they
actually did something rather than
nothing
um
you know oftentimes a perfectionist
focuses too much on
things that turn out to be
irrelevant so that keeps them from
actually being able to focus on things
that are more relevant
and that's a kind of
privation or lack as well
and i would say that another thing
that's really lacking in perfectionists
and again i have to admit that this this
affects me as well
thankfully less than i used to
is um
what's often missing is a sense of
proportion
and i don't mean just a sense of
proportion
about
you know individual
things or instances or projects or
things like that i don't mean that the
person lacks a sense of proportion
totally so that they can't get anything
right
i mean that once they get involved with
something that they value and which they
think other people value
they tend to
lose a sense about
how important things actually are in
relation to each other so you know for
example i'll give you a an example i
just finished turning in grades
for two classes of ethics students
from this last semester
and i inevitably get some some students
emailing me
who already have an a in the class
and they're concerned because they
didn't get the full points on this thing
or that thing or this thing
and now why does that show a lack of
proportion well if what they're really
concerned about is scores
it's not going to make any difference if
they get you know an extra 10 points
here and an extra 10 points there
they've already got the eight for the
class there are no a pluses at maris so
you know thank god for that because
otherwise i have people like grade
grubbing for every little tiny little
little bit that they can get
um
and they pour
now now what do we mean by a lack of
proportion
does that mean that that 10 points
doesn't matter at all no it's 10 points
but it's not going to make any
difference
and here's the key thing they're
throwing away time
energy
even to a certain extent
good will
can can be lost in the process as well
by
insisting i i need to have an answer
about this
and you know myself in the past i have
to admit that i would look at that and
i'd get you know
indignant about it now i just kind of
feel sorry for the person who
who uh
gets gets into that that sort of
trap of perfectionism
where it doesn't make any difference
it would be sort of like washing a table
and you know there's there's still like
one little speck on it but nobody's ever
going to eat on that table again
and the table's already been cleared you
don't need to to do it any further than
that
um
you know another thing to ask as long as
we're raising these big questions about
perfectionism if we want to fully
understand it so we've got you know what
is the typical action what is the
typical affect or desire or
emotion or motivation
what tends to be missing
you can add to that um
who are they trying to please and the
perfectionist often doesn't really
have a good handle on this again i you
know speaking from experience
in the process you can ask them well who
are you trying to please and they'll be
able to point to some sort of you know
standard or person who's evaluating them
or perhaps themselves
but it's not really thought through very
well and as soon as you start peeling it
away you find out that maybe they're
trying to please
somebody else maybe it's kind of
amorphous maybe they have no idea who
they're trying to please there's just
this sort of tyranny of standards
self-imposing itself
upon them
who are they trying to impress
who are they trying to satisfy
that's really worth thinking about and
this isn't the sort of thing that you
can answer
right off the bat this is if you are a
perfectionist this is the sort of thing
that you kind of have to mull over
and you have to think about from
situation to situation you know
understanding these sorts of things is
not just a matter of having one aha
moment an epiphany where everything
comes into view it's really and this is
you know
this is kind of typical of the problem
of the perfectionist the perfectionist
would love for there to be something
like that where everything clicks
but that's not the way it really works
that's not the way moral progress
actually takes place for the most part
for for most people what happens you get
a little bit of
insight here
and
you you know you keep working at it and
expanding it you get a little bit over
here and keep working at it and expand
it and then maybe you bring those
together and then you get a little bit
more here you just start changing some
of your habits and pay close attention
to what you think and how you you
treat yourself and how you you know uh
you make some resolutions about what
you're going to do next time and you
fail in half of those and then you just
you know evaluate why you failed in
those and and then you know actually
start congratulating yourself for the
ones where you didn't and gradually you
start you start making some progress
well you know figuring out these
questions like who are you really trying
to to impress or please or satisfy
if your perfectionist is kind of like
that
you know the other thing that you can
ask
that's really important is what are what
are the results of being a perfectionist
and this is where
well this is really the the handle
by which you might actually get a grip
on it and decide you want to
investigate it or even change it
the perfectionist does not actually
bring about what it is that they
they aim at
it doesn't really work out the way that
they they want to even when everything
turns out to be quite good
what are the results well they they
they sort of misinvest time and energy
enthusiasm
effort
and that means that they got to take it
away from somewhere else you know you
only get 24 hours in a day so if you're
spending an extra two hours on some sort
of project that really didn't bear you
know that you've got to take those two
hours from somewhere else
if you only have so much energy uh you
know you can boost it a little bit by
drinking yourself some coffee but that
that's a you know there's a diminishing
return on that that's not gonna carry
you through all the time
what are some other results well you
know perfectionism
it's not just what what you
end up doing or what you end up leaving
out
it's
also the dissatisfaction that you end up
feeling yourself
many my students who are perfectionists
talk in terms of anxiety
being anxious about about say grades for
example or
about doing well in the class some of
them you know even are concerned about
how i view them you know they turn in an
assignment late and they don't want me
to think of them as the kind of person
who turns in an assignment late and i'll
write them and i'll say you know i i
understand life is
complicated sometimes things fall
through the cracks you know we forget
things that's why i set things up so you
can still turn in your assignments late
you know and generally i actually you
know give them
if not
full credit pretty close to it because i
i want them to actually do the work
that's involved
and they're less focused quite often on
why i want them to do the work which is
the big picture that's the you know
student learning right and they're more
focused on i got to get this done i got
to get this done oh god i hope i did you
know i didn't screw it up and i did it
the right way and and you know dr sadler
doesn't think bad of me for turning it
in late and i'll never let this happen
again and they get you know wound up
into this sort of thing for me you know
i i
i have something like that when it comes
to time i don't like being late for
anything
and i i feel bad you know sometimes
when i'm late to say grade student stuff
i try to get that turned around as
quickly as possible
so that students have their their work
right away and i actually you know i
feel bad when i when i don't but i've at
least gotten to the point where i
recognize hey that's going to happen
from time to time
for me the perfectionism tends to
exhibit itself more in the kind of work
and research and writing
and course development that i do i i try
to make my courses to be
the best they can possibly be for for
the students so i'm constantly adding
new resources and developing
handouts and
shooting videos you know
like for instance this talking about
perfectionism and the question is you
know for you
how much time are you going to put into
this and and how good does it have to be
does it you know
with videos for example do i need to
have like an intro thing with some music
you know
um
do i need to annotate everything so that
you know somebody could follow each each
idea out you know with with written
stuff as well as you know me talking
you know at a certain point if you want
to get out of being a perfectionist you
have to train yourself to say
that's good enough
and that's really scary for a
perfectionist because one of the reasons
why
somebody is a perfectionist
is because
they are not very good at identifying
what actually is good enough
and part of that has to do with you know
this question of who are you actually
trying to please
if you've if you've had to try to please
people
for whom nothing was ever good enough
or
you know i've known people for example
who
when they did well then it was sort of a
neutral response and then anything less
than that got a
you did badly response
if that's the case you're going to have
a very difficult time figuring out what
actually is good enough particularly
indeterminate circumstances you're going
to look actually for some sort of
standard for what's good enough rather
than developing the prudence that's
required within you to be able to say
yeah in this circumstance this counts is
good enough in this circumstance this
counts is good enough and they're not
always exactly the same
so we've covered a lot of ground i want
to say a few other things
one is that perfect
is a relative term
and
there's one exception to this and that's
if you have a certain kind of ontology
or metaphysics which actually thinks
that there is a perfect being out there
or something like degrees
of of being where there's some some sort
of thing at the apex and that is not us
human beings if you actually have a
metaphysics like that somebody like that
would be say for example plato or
saint anselm or saint thomas aquinas
people who believed in you know if not
the god of
judaism christianity you know these
monotheistic religions
the form of the good or something like
that some sort of
ontological
principle
of perfection
that
would be the apex and that we would in
some way participate in
there we're talking very metaphysical
stuff we're not talking about the
everyday phenomenal world that we move
in and experience and
um
in which we act like perfectionists so
let's think about other meanings of of
perfect where it is relative
so you know one one sense of the word
perfect is when you satisfy some sort of
standard so i i give a an exam
and it's got say multiple choice
questions and fill in the blank
questions and then some short answer
questions some essay questions and the
exam is worth 100 points and if you
answer everything completely correctly
you have a perfect score
now that score is a proxy
it doesn't necessarily mean you have
perfect knowledge right you have a score
that's perfect
in relation to the set of standards
that's been provided you
and we can do this for artificial things
um
you know
you can talk about
i don't know i mean can you talk about
say the perfect size for a book
yeah i don't know
there there probably isn't one it's
going to depend on a lot of a lot of
circumstances you know is this book the
perfect size is this book the perfect
size
this book is you know a pocket book so
you know it fit into certain pockets but
but not all of them and you know you got
to ask yourself who sets these these
standards and how important are these
standards
a lot of times people get so caught up
in i need some standards i need
something that i can measure up to i got
i got to figure out what my you know
what i have to do in this case and they
don't ask themselves well
what's the actual point here
is it to
find you know the the standards get on
the dean's list
how do you get on the dean's list you
got to get a certain grade point average
well you know is that really that
important
it's not actually
i knew people who obsessed over it
i have to admit i i did to some degree i
was interested in so much bigger
things as well like graduating you know
summa [ __ ] laude
when i was an undergraduate
or you know when i took my preliminary
examinations i remember how humiliating
it was that on my master's examination i
got a low pass in part over some kind of
you know bs things you know some some
criticisms that probably were off base
and then how you know
great i felt when i got high passes on
on
three out of four of my my preliminary
examinations at the master's level but
you know when it comes down to it does
that really mean anything not much
not in the long run
i mean
these are not great predictors of how
you're going to do in the future
you can get an a on on one of my ethics
exams and then you know
you've managed to
remember all that stuff for the test
then you forget it the next day and it
doesn't make any impact on your life or
you can be the kind of person who
actually gets a 75 but you you retain
the stuff because you actually cared
about it and you thought about it and
you made it part of your new existence
and
the person who's actually successful
is not the one who got the hundred the
person who's successful is the one who
carried it forward
so you know simply satisfying standards
having perfect scores is is uh it's not
really perfection in in a real sense
are there any other senses that that are
more meaningful you can say not let you
know not lacking it not having any sort
of blemish not lacking any sort of thing
that it ought to have
like you know is this a perfect pen well
it's not perfect anymore because you
know it's not completely full
so i guess it was perfect when it was
first created and i guess if we looked
at some of these things we'd find you
know
pits and
blemishes and stuff like that
um
that's not a particularly useful way of
understanding perfection either
i know that that's one that we use you
can talk about somebody having a perfect
body
get close enough to anybody and it turns
out not to be perfect i mean the hdtv
has been great for showing us that
suddenly all these people who
were tv worthy before turned out to have
all these you know facial blemishes that
we didn't realize they they had
um
are there any other meanings that could
be useful well you know you can say best
in relation to certain things so you
have the highest score up until this
point you're perfect
and the perfectionist might be aiming at
that just surpassing everybody else
i know that tended to be the kind of
perfectionism
that i
really had a problem with
in the in the past and i guess still
probably
have some problem with in certain
respects in the present
you know
if you're involving yourself in a lot of
comparison to to
others sometimes that takes away from
actually focusing on what you yourself
are doing
i would like to say that if we want to
get away from perfectionism we need a
different conception of perfection
and i would say
that if you want to find where that that
better conception of it lies it's
actually in ancient and medieval
philosophy it's not lacking any blemish
or anything like that it's tied to an
understanding of something as being
perfect when it's the way it ought to be
when it's fulfilling its purpose
when it's
realizing its potential
and that's you know that's a matter of
degrees and something
can be
in a certain sense perfect without being
entirely
developed being completely at its end
you know if you think about
a plant for example
we'll take corn you know everyone wants
to use an acorn and oak and i'm kind of
tired of that example take corn because
i'm from corn growing areas so i know a
lot about corn you put it in the the
furrows
and it pops up and it's shooting up and
you know you don't you don't expect it
to be
eight feet tall immediately right i mean
knee high by the fourth of july is the
old the old saying uh although the new
stuff shoots up a lot quicker than that
because you know it's all genetically
modified but
if it's knee-high by the fourth of july
you're on good track
that's sort of a measure that we used in
the midwest for for corn it's got to
shoot up and it's got to produce these
tassels and then it's got to produce
ears and the ears have to have at least
a certain you know
size of kernels and then we call and
then it's perfect it's it's done what it
ought to do
and it's the same way with with you
for so many things
you don't have to find some sort of
somebody else given artificial standard
that tells you okay here's where you
have to be this is exactly what you have
to be
see whether the things that you're doing
are actually working out adopt a more
pragmatic conception
of perfection one though that's in line
with ancient and medieval thought which
saw us as
being part of a cosmos in which each
thing
had its own way of developing and you
know thomas aquinas for example said
the nature of a thing
you only get to see the nature of the
thing fully when it's been fully
developed so and he gives examples like
a horse well horses aren't that tough to
figure out but a human being is so much
more complicated let alone a
house or a family a family can be
thought of as something that undergoes
development
people try to have these perfect
families and
you know sometimes they're just
hellish
because they misunderstand perfection
and and perfectionism
is really a misunderstanding of the
nature of perfection so the last thing
i'm going to talk about are a few
paradoxes of perfectionism
and again
things that i know through bitter
experience
and had to you know work my own way
through it and i can do another video
talking about some of some of the
specific specifics of that some other
time
here's one paradox
perfectionism is an adaptation to one's
environment to one's history to one's
you know the conditions that one lives
in that's actually maladaptive
so it's an adaptation to produce
to change oneself into something that
that is is you know producing producing
producing attaining certain things but
is actually maladaptive because you're
missing out on things
and you're
cutting yourself short from from some
satisfaction for yourself
most perfectionists are not happy people
um
here's another paradox it involves so
much energy and attention
that it keeps the person from noticing
all the other things that are going on
and from reflecting on them so
you know
perfection for a human being would
involve growth perfectionism actually
stifles growth because it produces a
sort of
building in a kind of way
but it keeps you from actually expanding
and growing because it keeps you from
paying attention to the larger
universe and the the you know matrix of
of other human beings that you're caught
up with it keeps you from actually
knowing yourself
and
that way it sort of hinders your own
growth
another paradox is it prevents a person
who has it from developing the prudence
that's actually needed
to determine what counts as good enough
and what would actually count as
genuinely perfect
prudence is not something that you're
born with it's something that you have
to develop and cultivate over time
and it doesn't happen in everybody
sometimes it takes bitter experience and
humiliation and screwing up and then you
know reflecting on that and trying to
get your life on track i know i've got a
lot of
uh cases like that for myself where it's
uh it's through sorrow and suffering
that that i i wound up
learning some things that i you know
other people were telling me but i
wasn't paying attention
um
sometimes it's through having you know
good people that you actually learn from
and model yourself after and listen to
and who genuinely care for you and uh
who can help you to understand what what
actually counts as good enough in which
direction you should be going
uh and that that scores by themselves
are really not that important they're
not the thing that you can you can
nourish yourself with um
so anyway prudence that's something that
that the the perfectionist unfortunately
lacks
and yet they think that they're they're
one of the most prudent people in the
world quite often
the most prudent thing is if you're a
perfectionist is to actually realize
that you're a perfectionist
and then to start working on getting
away from that
the last thing and this is probably the
most important thing
this is the reason why perfectionism is
a failing strategy for dealing with life
for dealing with uh the kind of things
that you you have to do in life
anything that's valuable
in the world in life in yourself is
complicated because reality is
complicated and when things are
complicated that means that you can see
them from multiple angles from multiple
sides
and
what counts is perfect from one vantage
point
you change the vantage point a little
bit and now you can see the blemishes
and the imperfections involved
the last thing i'm going to say about
about perfectionism really it ties
everything else in together and
it's it's something that's really
important to keep in mind
um it has to do with the nature of
reality and the things that we find
valuable
so i mean here's the bottom line
anything that that is actually
worthwhile valuable
out in the world in your relations with
other people
in yourself in the things that you
produce
anything along those lines is always
going to be complex and it's usually
going to be more complex than than
you're taking in at any given point and
it's always going to be more complex
than any particular measure
of it that you're engaging in
so
you might think of it this way
everything has multiple sides you know
for instance this pen you can see it
from from different angles right and you
can see it multiple ways it looks very
different in this way when you want to
go right with it then when you do this
just a simple thing but you've already
changed the perspective on it you've
changed the nature of it i break off
this piece right here and now it won't
cling to my pocket
that changes the perspective as well you
know coffee mug as if it's full of
coffee that's good the coffee is not hot
necessarily well then that's not so good
so anything that you look at anything
that you're going to evaluate and try to
make perfect
as soon as you change your perspective
the imperfections show up
and what that should
make you think about
is the fact that the goal is not to try
to maximize
perfection
because you can never do it you can
never no matter if you just pick one
single thing
one single aspect about yourself you
can't take that and make that from every
single perspective one might look at it
into something
absolutely perfect in parkas what if you
put it next to something else
or what if you put it in the context of
your whole life and you say i invested
you know half my life into this this one
thing that's a failed life
most likely unless that was some really
really important thing and if it was you
probably didn't make it perfect yourself
you're probably collaborating with other
people and it probably still isn't
perfect
anyway
so
you know the thing that you want to do
is start thinking less in terms of
you might say artificially imposed and
unthought about
just assumed standards of perfection and
start actually thinking about what what
do i mean when i say i want things to be
perfect when i want myself to be perfect
what is my conception of of perfection
do i have the right conception of
perfection
because see that's one of the paradoxes
of perfectionism
perfectionism
gets perfection wrong and is thereby
imperfect
so that's where i'll leave off a lot of
reflections on this but something really
important something that i've you know
had to struggle with a lot myself and i
you know anybody that this helps out
there
in thinking about these things
i'm glad if it helps you if not
you know maybe you wasted you know 20
minutes of your time but
unless you're a perfectionist
maybe that's not such a bad thing